не роздавати голосні порожні
обіцянки виявилися з'єднання криму і
севастополя з росією зрозуміло під
реформи саме тут знаходиться духовний
витоків формування багатоликого але
монолітні російської нації та
централізованого російського
держави
адже саме тут у криму у стародавньому
херсонесі або як його називали росіяни
літописці курсу не прийняв хрещення князь
владимир а потім і хрестив всю русь як
у зв'язку мережі можна підтримати
збройне захоплення влади
насильства та вбивства одні криваві події
в одесі чого варте коли людей спалювали
живцем повторю
як можна це підтримати запитуєте
навіщо все це було зроблено на
україні та заради чого вчинили
держпереворот заради чого стріляли досі
пір стріляють і вбивають людей по суті
зруйнували економіку фінансової
соціальну сферу
розорили країну за посиленням Росії
ми завжди пишалися своєї країни, але ми
не претендуємо на звання
якийсь наддержава розуміється як
претензія на світову чи регіональну
гегемонію не покушаємо сянь інакше інтерес
нікому не нав'язуємо своє
заступництво нікого не намагаємося вчити
жити зараз наше завдання створити
багату та благополучну росію при цьому
хочу, щоб усі ми чітко розуміли
найближчі роки будуть вирішальними і може
бути навіть переломними і не тільки для
нас а практично для всього світу який
вступає в епоху кардинальних
Зміна може бути навіть і потрясіння
звертаю увагу звертаю увагу
сучасній Росії потрібна армія, що має
всі можливості адекватно реагувати на
сучасні ж загрози у нас із вами
мають бути збройні сили здатні
одночасно вести боротьбу у глобальному
регіональним, а якщо потрібно і в
кількох локальних конфліктах
співробітництво забезпечення глобальної та
регіональної стабільності нарощувати
обсяги взаємної торгівлі інвестиції
розвивати